die post ist da die post ist da die post
ist da und damit herzlich willkommen
sagte stuck nummer 18
und ich glaube die weihnachtskarten sind
gekommen sei ich war unter der dusche
und bin auch noch am schneiden aber
diesen moment muss ich festhalten
es müsste dass sein haus dem platz taten
kriegt dieses paket dort leute ich bin
zugestimmt also erstmal die drei
millionen briefumschläge das sind keine
klappkarten es sind sowieso eine
postkarte finde ich aber nicht schlimm
weil sonst müsste man noch weil wir
haben 40 stück bestellt dann müsste man
40 mal was schreiben und dann habe ich
das einfach am computer da geschrieben
ok sieht aber aus wenn ich das jetzt so
sehe
wir sind eine hochzeitseinladung royale
weihnacht die weihnachtsgaben sind da
aber ich sage der andere druck wäre
besser gewesen weil das am computer
besser rübergekommen ist und mit zum
goldenen rand und schrift aber keiner
auf mich verarscht und sieht absolut
neues aus wie das was glänzt das sieht
aus als wären wir fucking weil sie nicht
prinz von england und seine queen the
next level aus also diese gold stanzerei
hier ist die kläger aus habe ich finde
es aber sei es besser das haben die
schnauze lücke sieht einfach aus ist
wenn man clean von england und selbst
von engen
das stimmt aber wie ich es auch so
perfekt wenn du das einfach so dann
verschickt und dann machst du das auf
holz so was von briefen die dann sind
einfach wie ihr
ich bin ich schwierigkeiten vielleicht
regungen mitgehen und dann soll aber ich
habe schwierigkeiten diese karte
anzugucken
ich bin vollauf zufrieden leute muss ja
auch ein bisschen drehen dass dieses
glanz rüberkommen von bernau
wahrscheinlich einfach nur deswegen kann
ich nicht richtig anschauen
ich werde ein foto davon machen auf
instagram posten und wenn ihr eine
zugeschickt haben wollt also ich glaube
ich verstehe so zehn stück meine
zuschauer dann schreibt einfach in die
kommentare
folgt mir auf instagram und bleibt
dieses video
aber das ist euch frei überlassen jetzt
brauchen wir nur in wachs siegel das
muss ich heute bei einem bastelladen
holen in der bastel leben haben wachsen
es war ein bastel eines da könnte ich
hinfahren ich bin noch nicht fertig
geschnitten aber ich habe schon mal
gekauft und zwar gab ist also ich hab's
vergessen zu filmen
es gab schon mit brauner butter wo ich
ein bisschen mit der bronx oder
übertrieben habe kartoffelbrei und
spiegler dazu das war lecker oder
unvorteilhafte aber weil ihr so kleine
perverse schweine seit zeige ich euch
wie ich aufräume oman muslime das macht
ihr denn da oben meine gewesen
schweinchen besteht darauf werde ich
aufräume also bitteschön jetzt clean
china
[Musik]
ich weiß also ich habe eben gerade eine
migräne bekommen hat sich diese pakete
ausgepackt hat deswegen fand ich die
karte so unglaublich verstören und
konnte gar nicht richtig sie im privaten
das liegt nämlich daran wenn ich eine
migräne bekomme tun meine augen extra
sie tue nicht weh aber ich kann nicht
mehr gucken ich kann nicht mehr richtig
fokussieren an dass es irgendwie
verschwommen und ja der focus fehlt und
deswegen habe ich diese karten gucken
sagt mir so hermann kann er sich
überhaupt diese schrift konzentrieren
und ja sie ist ganz schön versteckt und
dezent aber das macht mir vielleicht
auch gerade so besonders dass wenn man
irgendwo stehen hat dass man sich erst
mal nur das bild sieht und dann wenn man
ran geht sieht man auch schön reale
weihnacht blöde obwohl ich glaube ich
hätte dort noch gerne 20 von den anderen
karten gehabt einfach nur um zu sehen
wie die anderen ausgesehen hätten
aber es auch
ein loch ich mein kommen so eine
weihnachtskarte ist heute schon nächste
level so und jetzt schnell weiter
schneiden damit ich noch diese wachs
dinge kaufen kann und wie die heute noch
zur post bringen können das wäre nämlich
tiptop der blog wird heute einfach so 30
minuten lang aber ich glaube das ist
ganz cool ich mag's bei den bilder zum
beispiel die folgen dinge sind also ich
hab das video geschnitten und
hochgeladen ist eine stunde zu spät
eingegangen
und ich habe wieder shane dawson make-up
drauf dass man wahrscheinlich nicht so
gut sieht durch so schön im spiegel sah
wunderschön aus und jetzt machen wir das
die leute denken auch du sitzt immer nur
auf der couch das türchen nummer 17 und
wir gehen heute sogar noch essen und
zwar um ein grad gerne mehr
machen können diese steuer bewusstes
verschmelzen diese übung kannst du
überall wo du etwas ungestört bist
durchführen
setz dich hin und entspanne dich und
stell dir vor dass du mit deiner
umgebung verschmilzt mit etwas übung
wirst du dich bald eins mit deiner
umgebung fühlen versuche dies mehrfach
täglich da ist eine weile dauern kann
bis du die übung beherrscht
achte darauf dass deinen geist zu klären
entspanne dich völlig und verschmelzen
die verschmelzung ist mit der coach
die perfekte vorstellbar die sind
richtig felix premium beim barbecue
haben wir natürlich so bestellt und
natürlich ein leckeres koreanisches bier
wegen meiner migräne habe ich die finger
von lassen aber ich würde es sonst super
doll empfehlen weil es echt lecker
schmeckt sache an eine migräne tag bier
und so zu trinken sehr gut vanessa
[Musik]
und team ok hat wie das essen muss
sommer sind die gerade in rohan bei den
pferde leuten
ich habe vergessen meine kamera
mitzunehmen zum essen war er ganz kurz
ich sage ganz gut gepasst meine kamera
mit zunehme wangen hat beim barbecue wie
fandest du es war ein konzert das ich im
hintergrund weiter
wann war das denn das war vor 19 jahren
hat das shooting ich kann mich kaum
erinnern oder er hat uns dieser eine
bekannte maler aus der renaissance-zeit
ja das war dieses royale dreck bringt
vielleicht sind wir auch einfach vampire
und einfach schon so seit 300 jahren am
leben
so sieht das auch so ein bisschen anders
morgen werde ich die briefe und sowas
abschicken ich werde eine riesen
verlosung machen weil ich heute noch ein
paar nachbestellt habe das heißt ich
werde 30 karten verlosen riesen
verlosung ihr kriegt so eine karte man
wird da auch noch unterschreiben können
auch warum könnte ich da schreibe 500
leute die schreiben bitte macht ein auto
drauf
doch macht er
macht er von der kommentare die sagen
'bitte unterschreibt die karte also dass
die verlosung des bald jetzt auf
instagram wahrscheinlich jetzt in der
wohnung ja jetzt gibt es den integra und
morgen wenn ich auf jeden fall das wachs
holen für dieses siegel und wir brauchen
ein siegel und dann verstehe ich die
ganzen weihnachtskarten und morgen
dekorieren werden die kekse auch und ich
muss nochmal das heißt viel passiert
ich freue mich drauf und hoffe wir sehen
uns morgen wieder biss dann gute nacht
sagen cookie monster
[Musik]